y mi entrada de extranjeros son
nacionales ni salida de ciudadanos que
estén en territorio chileno a partir del
lunes 5 de abril y hasta el final del
mes chile cerrará sus fronteras se puede
solicitar una en caso de situación
extraordinaria a través de comisaría
virtual un permiso para salir pero esta
situación extraordinaria sólo puede ser
porque es fundamental para el país
porque hay una medida humanitaria de por
medio porque es esencial para la salud o
porque la persona que sale no vuelve el
sistema sanitario se encuentra al borde
del colapso con un 96% de las unidades
de cuidados intensivos ocupadas esto
pese a que el 83 por ciento de la
población está confinada también para
todos aquellos camiones que ingresan por
frontera terrestre que son esenciales
para el abastecimiento se les exigirá
con 72 horas de anticipación un pcr
negativo en las zonas de cuarentena
total y en las que el confinamiento rige
sólo los fines de semana los
supermercados no podrán vender productos
que no sean esenciales y a las personas
solo
los permisos individuales semanales para
salir de sus domicilios pese a su
avanzada campaña de vacunación que ha
permitido inocular a más de 67 millones
de ciudadanos el país continúa batiendo
recortes de casos y de muertes este
jueves superó el millón de contagios y
el total de fallecidos se ubica en más
de 23.000 esta comunicación tan
triunfalista respecto de que somos el
país que más rápido ha cuna que somos
felicitado internacionalmente que vamos
a lograr la inmunidad primero que nadie
mandó una señal a las personas respecto
de un cierto relajo y ese les es la
crítica internacional
el gobierno también determinó adelantar
el toque de queda en todo el país a
partir del 5 de abril regirá entre las
nueve de la noche y las cinco de la
mañana